hello everyone so today we will start
discussing the topic of shear centre
which happens to be the final topic of
the end semester portion of our course
of Atmos mechanics of solids now frankly
speaking this topic is not that advanced
nevertheless as we begin learning it we
will note that there will be a few
twists and turns along the way about
which we should be really careful and so
we should approach this topic with all
humility because as we learn it you will
see that we'll have to question how well
we have understood some of the basic
undergraduate concepts now what we are
going to do is not directly go into the
definition of the shear Center rather
we'll start our discussion by falling
back on what we had been discussing in
the previous two lectures and then use
that as a natural motivation which will
help us induce so to speak the
definition of shear Center so going back
to the previous two lectures what we
were discussing back then was
unsymmetrical bending now now a very
important point to note regarding that
discussion and I had emphasized that a
few times during that lecture during
those lectures was that the entire
mathematical framework that we had
developed as regards to unsymmetrical
bending it pertained to a case of pure
bending so
so it put it to the case of pure bending
now what do you even mean by that what
do you mean by pure bending well we have
to understand that back then when we
derived those formula for the bending
stress and and the orientation for the
neutral axis through the tan beta
expression we kept on using the the
variables my and MZ to denote the Y and
the Z components of the bending moments
however those bending moments would
actually be induced by the application
of some mechanical forces on the beam so
to take a quick concrete example suppose
we consider a cantilever beam like this
and we consider this kind of tip loading
now we understand and know very well
from our undergraduate studies that if
we take a generic cut section like this
will have some kind of
bending moment induced here they'll also
be a shear force now from the from the
front view of this diagram so to speak
concretely about the plane let's orient
our x axis like this our y axis like
this so that the z axis is pointing out
of the plane so so the plane that we are
talking about here in the bottom diagram
so here we are basically looking at the
XY plane now we have to understand that
if we go to a different orientation of
view then this picture is not going to
look so simple so for instance if we
look at the XZ plane then the
cross-section of the beam will actually
come into view so for example the
cross-section in the XZ plane
sorry this will be the Y Z plane so let
me make that clear so this will be the Y
Z plane it may look like a square or a
rectangle it could also look like this
kind of a circle so please understand
that this is this is supposed to be a
circle this one or in general as we had
been discussing during unsymmetrical
bending it could take any arbitrary
cross-section now what is very important
to understand is that this force that we
this this transversely oriented force
that we are considering here in this
particular orientation of the Y Z plane
it may not look necessarily vertically
downward as we had talked about a non
symmetrical bending however even if the
the transverse load this one is parallel
to the y axis here we need to be careful
in understanding the situation so what
do I mean by that so consider this
suppose we take a circular cross section
for the beam and we draw a diagram like
this
so this is our wall
and
the way that I have drawn this diagram
so this is this diagram here is exactly
this one here but in a different view so
this force that I have drawn here will
be depicted by a force like this now the
way that I have drawn here it seems that
it is very much passing through the
center of this okay now this is the
simplest of situations we can think of
however what could happen is that this
particular force is not passing through
this center rather it is a little bit
eccentric from the center then what
could happen well as you can intuitively
guess we could have a situation in that
case where this been not only bends but
also twists so what we mean by that is
that this force is going to induce a
torsional moment which will have a
tendency which will which will make this
beam to twist around this longitudinal
axis well
it seems fairly simple to understand but
let us try to prove this idea a bit
further so let's go to the next page and
consider this
so let's draw our circular cross-section
and let us Depok let's draw that again
and
and let us denote the force like this
which we understand has a line of action
which passes through the centroid now
the moment we start discussing about the
possibility of such a force having a
twisting action or a torsion we know
that in this particular case there will
be no twisting action but what are we
actually saying in that case what we are
saying is that we are taking the moment
of this force here about an axis which
is going into the plane and passing
through this point so I repeat when you
are saying that this force has no
twisting action or no torsion what we
are basically saying is that this is not
contributing to any torsional moment
when we consider the moment about an
axis which is passing about an axis
which is going into the plane and which
is passing through this point but
suppose we ask ourselves this question
that instead of a of an axis which is
going into the plane but which does not
pass to this point rather which goes
through another point suppose we
consider an axis like this which goes
into the plane but through this point
then what about the torsional moment
contributed by this force well in that
case the torsional moment is not going
to be zero so what I am saying here is
that if we consider the line of action
of this this will have a non zero moment
arm which is this distance and it will
definitely induce a non zero torsional
moment this force will induce a non zero
torsional moment but then the question
arises just because we are considering
such a different axis as this one
instead of this one
does it mean that this very same force
which was previously not inducing any
torsional moment now it is inducing it's
it seems to appear some kind of
torsional moment as a result of of just
a different choice of our axis is it
going to induce some kind of twisting
for this beam the answer of course is no
it is exactly the same physical
situation it is only our geometrical
choice of the axis which has changed so
that cannot change the physical picture
and therefore even if we considered this
axis there cannot be any possibility of
a twisting induced by this force but
then what what is happening to the non
zero torsional moment that we are
getting when we are considering this
axis okay so will answer that question
as part of our discussion next what we
want to do is we will again consider
this circle the circular cross-section
so it is the exact same circular
cross-section
although it looks a little bit different
here but that's just my bad drawing what
we'll do is instead of a force like this
we are going to apply a force which is a
little bit eccentric to begin with well
in this case most of you can intuitively
understand that there should be some
kind of twisting induced in the beam
because of this force so when we say
that what we are empirically doing is
taking the torsional moment of this
force about an axis which is going into
the plane and which is passing through
this centroid
and that would be absolutely correct
that the torsional moment is indeed
nonzero but suppose I say that and this
is exactly what this is exactly similar
to the discussion that we just had as
regards to this diagram so here also
what I will do is I will take another
axis which is just to the left of this
to this previous axis but which is
falling in the line of action of this
force so here so now if we try to take
or if you try to find out the torsional
moment of this force about this axis it
is certainly going to give us zero
because the moment arm is equal to zero
and again just like we had asked
ourselves in this diagram that just
because we have taken a different sort
of axis does it mean that the the result
the apparent result of the torsional
moment coming out to be zero about this
means that it is going to be having zero
twist twisting action here the answer is
certainly not just because we have taken
a different sort of axis it's not going
to be like that so there will be a
definite twisting in this case there
will be no twisting in this case so if
we focus just on what the torsional
moment is as regards to the applied
force like this or the applied force
like this but take different choices of
the sin of the of the axis about which
we are taking the torsion moment like
here here here or here then we see
doesn't give us a very concrete picture
so what exactly is going on why are we
getting why are we ending up with this
sort of confusion so it is our aim here
to to remove this confusion through our
discussion of you know the the very
basic topic of shear centre
so to briefly recap what we have been
discussing till now if we go back to the
previous page we had considered this
kind of a transverse force which we
understood induce some kind of bending
which we all understand very well but at
the same time if we look at the Y Z
plane which we did here and we
considered this kind of a force which
would still look very much vertically
downward in the XY plane but which is
clearly off-center looking at the Y Z
plane we understand that the very same
Force which was inducing the bending in
the previous page here would be inducing
along with the bending moment some kind
of torsion also so I repeat myself
that when we have a transverse force
acting on a beam then in general that
transverse force can induce not only
bending but also twisting so the next
question which we ask ourselves is that
in the previous two lectures in the
context of unsymmetrical bending when we
kept referring to pure bending what did
we mean well what we meant was that we
were considering the kind of
applications of forces which would be
inducing solely and solely bending and
no such twisting now you note that we
have been having this discussion as
regards to transverse forces it is also
possible that we can have forces which
are not transverse rather parallel to
the longitudinal axis of the beam in
which case it is very much possible to
have not only bending moment but also
twisting but in addition to those two
also
axial forces but for the purpose of our
current discussion will be only
referring to these kinds of transverse
forces where there is a possibility of
bending moment as well as a possibility
of torsion or twisting and for the
purpose of our discussion of shear
Center we will be focusing on the very
special case as to when these transverse
forces will induce only bending and no
twisting so we write this down
and the important question which we ask
is is it possible
to have a case
when the transverse forces
induce only bending
so there is a question mark there well
it's not really a question because in
the previous two discussions in the
previous two lectures I had been saying
time and again that we are going to
consider a case of pure bending so it is
of course very much true the answer is
yes answer is yes definitely it is
possible to have a case when the
transverse force will induce only
bending and no twisting and that is the
case when these transverse forces pass
through a very special point and that
point is is what is the what is called
the shear centre so yes
when the transverse force
bosses through a special point
passes through a special point
called
this year centered
so a four-hour transverse force passes
through the shear Center there will be
no twisting okay now to be useful to
note down a couple of extremely
important points for the shear Center
so the first point is that the shear
Center
is a purely geometric entity
which means that
a particular cross section
we'll have a particular shear Center
that
does not change
with loading
so if we have a particular cross section
it will have a very definite shear
Center no matter what kind of loading we
put on it that is not going to change
another important point is that even
though the shear Center is a purely
geometric entity which has to do solely
with the geometry of the cross section
it is not necessary for the shear Center
to live within the cross section so the
shear Center need not lie within the
cross section and this will become
amplifier as we develop our discussions
now with this understanding we are
almost ready to launch into the
derivation or how to address the
question of how we can find out the
shear Center and as a first step towards
that goal of finding out the shear
Center for any given cross section what
we'll do is go back and redress the
confusing questions which which we had
been asking as regards to this circular
cross section so so what we were so the
questions that we will confused about to
quickly repeat myself is that when we
are considering these kinds of
transverse forces and we were
considering the torsional moments about
various axis which we are going into the
plane
sometimes we found out that it was
giving us zero values and sometimes it
was giving us nonzero values but but
that value coming out as zero on non
zero did not give us a clear-cut idea
about whether that about whether the the
beam would actually twist or not so when
we considered this force and considered
this axis we found out quite rightly the
there would be no twist but when you
considered this axis we found out that
they would be they would be a nonzero
torsional moment but that does not that
did not change the fact that they would
still be no twist similarly when we
considered this force here and
considered this axis we found out that
there would be a nonzero torsional
moment which kind of gave us that the
correct idea that there would be a twist
but when we considered this axis we
found out there was zero torsional
moment but that gave us the wrong idea
that there would be no twist because
they would be very much a twist here so
what is going on here and what is going
on here can be clearly understood if we
if we stop considering this kind of a
cross-section rather we considered the
the beam in its entirety so that's what
we are going to do so let me go to a new
page and this discussion that we are
going to have will not only address
those kinds of confusing questions but
it will also give us the the recipe to
address how to find out the shear centre
okay so let's redraw that diagram but
this time what we are going to do is we
are not going to consider that kind of a
simple circular cross-section rather
what we are going to do is we are going
to take some kind of general
cross-section so let's take a beam like
this
let's say the beam has this kind of some
kind of irregular cross-section
despite my what my what my drawing might
indicate please understand that this is
very much a prismatic beam meaning that
whatever the cross-section is here at
this end the same cross-section is
maintained all throughout the length of
the beam I'm stating this fact because
this cross-section doesn't look exactly
like this one but please pardon my
drawing okay so what we understand is
that this is a cantilever beam so
there'll be a wall here like this and
there will be some kind of transverse
force acting on it now so let's let's
denote the transverse force before going
forward so let's say it is acting
somewhere here
let's also draw the axis so let's say
this is our x axis this is our Y axis
and this is our z axis now previously
when we were considering the circular
cross section which would be a special
case of this general cross section we
were only considering the torsional
moment that would be induced by this
transverse force about an axis which
would be either this blue axis or
another axis which would be parallel to
this axis so we were considering this
axis or something like this and other
axis which was like this okay now the
important question which we must or the
important point which we must note is
that if there is indeed no twisting
action induced by this transverse force
then it really should not matter about
which ax
we are considering the torsional moment
so let me repeat myself
if it is indeed true that this force is
not inducing any twisting of the beam
then it really should not matter about
which axis we are considering the
torsional moment so how do we reconcile
these this this apparent contradiction
well what we need what we are missing in
this entire discussion is that when we
are considering the possibility of
twisting it should not be we should not
be considering this force in isolation
rather what we should be doing is we
should be considering a cut section of
this beam and then to consider the total
torsional moment that is contributed not
only by this transverse force but also
by the shear stresses which would be
exposed on a particular cross section or
a cut section so what do I mean by this
so for that let me actually take a cut
section so what I'll do is I'll take a
cut section here
and this car section would
okay
so this card section would would expose
a cross-section like this which would of
course be exactly like this because we
are considering a beam now if we remove
this cut section from there and draw it
separately so what I mean is I
I draw it separately here
then the free body diagram for this cut
out piece it would involve it would
involve this kind of this transverse
force definitely but on the exposed
surface which I will represent by hatch
here which is hidden away behind on that
hatch surface there will be a
distribution of of stresses which would
also be contributing to the torsional
moment if we choose to take the the
torsional moment about any axis now
please note that this has a direct
connection with our undergraduate
studies so no matter which background
you come from whether it is aerospace
engineering or mechanical engineering
you have invariably studied in your
undergraduate days that when you have
this kind of a transverse force then on
any cut section like this on any exposed
surface of a car section like this you
would have a shear a shear force so
suppose we were looking at the XY plane
then then to repeat our diagram from
from from from the first page it would
look something like this where our
transverse force would look like this to
remember that this is in the XY plane so
this is our X and this is our
this is our why and this is the said so
so we understand that there would be a
shear force like this and of course
there would be a bending moment like
this now
now coming back to this picture this
hatched part that I have shown here it
would have a distribution of shear
stresses in such a fashion that the
resultant of that of those shear
stresses in the vertical direction would
contribute to this shear force here I
repeat the distribution of shear
stresses on this hatched part would be
such that the resultant of that would be
contributing to this vertically oriented
shear force here and that in turn is
going to balance the effect of this
downward pointing externally applied
transverse force so whenever we have in
this kind of a situation it is actually
the shear stresses and the bending
stresses which you all know very well
about that is what is actually
responding to the external load okay and
this kind of a shear force is just a is
like a gross representation of the
entire contribution of that distribution
of shear stresses but pertinent to our
current discussion of shear centre and
the twisting action what we want to say
is that when we are going to consider or
when we want to write down or find out
the torsional moment of this one sure we
would be taking it about a certain
moment about a certain axis so suppose
we take it about about an axis which is
the x axis itself or suppose we choose
to take it about some other axis which
is parallel to
x-axis and which is denoted by X - it
doesn't matter we can choose to take the
moment on the torsional moment of this
externally applied force about any axis
as we had discussed earlier and we we
ended up with those confusing questions
but if we have to say anything
concretely about the net twisting action
that is seen or the net twist that is
seen in this cutaway piece and
consequently in the entire beam that we
were considering here so either you
consider this one or this one so
whatever happens here has a direct
consequence here so if we have to
consider the twist of this cut piece
then it is not enough to stop at just
the consideration of the torsional
moment of this one we have to consider
the torsional moment that is contributed
by the distribution of shear stresses
which is present here and this is the
most fundamental missing link which led
to the confusion in the earlier in the
earlier consideration of the circular
cross section so to summarize what what
I have been discussing is that it's true
that the consideration of torsional
moment of this force is going to give
either zero or nonzero values depending
on what kind of an axis we are choosing
here whether it is the x axis or the X
dash axis but the question of whether
this entire thing is undergoing a twist
can be answered only when we consider
not only the torsional moment of this
transverse force but also the torsional
moment that is contributed by the entire
distribution of shear stresses which is
present on this hatch section so tying
everything together if it so happens
that this externally applied transverse
force indeed passes through the shear
centre of the cross section then the
whole situation here will be such that
the entire distribution of shear
stresses here when we take the torsional
moment about an axis about any axis it
will turn out
to be to be such that it balances the
torsional moment here so again I repeat
myself if it so happens that this
transverse force passes through the
shear centre of the cross section then
no matter what kind of axis we choose to
take the torsional moment about the
torsional moment that is contributed by
this would be exactly balanced by the
torsional moment here if this transverse
force does not pass through the shear
Center then the torsional moment of this
about any axis would not be balanced by
the torsional moment of the distribution
of shear stresses about that very same
axis and this is the fundamental
important concept of this topic of shear
Center so let's read right and down
quickly
if the transverse force
passes through the shear Center
then the torsional moment
of
that force
about any axis here I'm not qualifying
the definition of any axis because I
just had this long discussion so this
any axis would be referring to any of
these axis which we understand is going
to be perpendicular to the cross section
so this is going to be the then the
torsional moment about of that force
about any axis is going to be balanced
contributed by the shear stresses
so let's write that has the shear
stresses on the hatched part
so when I say hatch part I basically
mean this one and please note that of
course this torsional moment contributed
by the shear stresses also has to become
computed about the very same axis
okay so this is the entire physical
understanding behind the shear Center
and the whole story associated with the
with the possibility of twisting under
the action of transverse forces now
let's come down to the practical aspects
of this calculation you see we have we
have done this discussion in association
with a beam having such an arbitrary
cross-section and whatever we have
discussed here is going to hold true no
matter what kind of a cross-section that
we have here but in practice it is not
very easy to find out the distribution
of shear stresses given any irregular
cross-section so if you have such a such
an irregular cross-section it is not at
all easy to find out the distribution of
shear stresses here and if you cannot
really find out the distribution of
shear stresses here so easily then how
are you going to find out or how are you
going to calculate the torsional moment
that we have mentioned here that is
contributed by this by this shear
stresses so so again talking about the
practical aspect of things it is alright
to discuss this thing in a very abstract
fashion but you have to remember that
these these discussions they all put
into structural mechanics where more
than this kind of an irregular section
which may be attractive for in
mathematical development what is really
useful immediately useful is to consider
some practically used cross sections and
this actually ties back to the
discussion that we had when we when were
discussing unsymmetrical bending where
we considered various kinds of cross
sections which were unsymmetrical but
which which had some great practical
importance like the dziak the z section
in the channel section of the c section
the L section and the I Section or even
the T section
so those are the kinds of cross sections
which are extremely important for
engineering practice and and keeping
those in mind the kind of theory that
will develop here will be burdening to a
very important aspect of of that of
those kinds of cross sections and that
important aspect is that all of those
cross sections whether it was the Z Z
section the L section the T section the
AI section all of them had a
characteristic that they were composed
of very thin members so the thickness of
of the various members which made up
that those sections was very very thin
and as long as we have those that kind
of a thin section or thin members making
up the cross section it is possible to
find out some kind of closed-form
expressions for the shear stresses and
that is what we are going to concentrate
on next